لا اريد ان اقول ان الادله كلها التي
قدمتها الولايات المتحده ولكن كل ما قدمته
الولايات المتحده علنا كان يستند في شكل
كبير الى وقائع غير صحيحه واعتقد ان كولن
باول الذي كان وزير خارجيه وقتها اقر بذلك
لاحقا عندما التقيته لانني سافرت ايضا الى
الولايات المتحده لاشرح الموقف الفرنسي
ولم يكن الامر دائما سهلا ولكن مع ذلك
ذهبت الى هناك
لم يكن موافقا تماما او لنقل لم يكن يتبنى
موقف الرئيس عندما التقيته وكذلك التقيت
كوندا ليسارايس وقتها وقلت لها انتبه انما
تقومون به خطا العراق
ولد تعددي صحيح ان موقعه مهم ولكن هناك
مواقف مختلفه وقد نخاطر بخلق منطقه غير
مستقره جورج
لاحقا فقالت لي لم تكوني على خطا امامنا
في تحليلك للوضع كان ذلك بعد الحرب بوقتا
طويل ولكنه كان اقرارا مهما وصحيح ان جاك
شراك كان لديه الكثير من الاهتمام لهذه
المنطقه من العالم لانه كان يجد ان هناك
الكثير من النقاط المشتركه التي نتقاسمها
فهو كان لديه علاقات شخصيه مع بعض القاده
في دول الخليج ولكنه ايضا كان يحرس على
اعتماد سياسه تجمع بين دفاع عن حقوق
الانسان التي في صميم قناعاته ولكن كان
ايضا يحرص على احترام الثقافات وسيادتي
الدول